I'm Gary Marcus AI expert and I'm here
to answer your questions on Twitter this
is AI support
[Music]
brand opiniony asks we'll chat GPT be
the end of the college essay Well
everybody's wondering that because it's
really easy to write essays with chat
TPT they're usually like csas not a
essays but it depends a lot on what the
professors and the teachers do I used to
be a professor what I would say is use
chatgpt but then let's talk about what
you got with it how could you make it
more interesting that wouldn't end the
essay it would just make it more
complicated and more fun and maybe teach
you how to think critically about
writing up next Andrew price asks us why
was 2022 the year when AI went
mainstream was it advances in consumer
Hardware knowledge transfer or something
else there's no one answer to that
there's a lot of reasons why AI is
starting to come together I would argue
it hasn't fully come together but people
got excited about it main reason they
got excited about it is because we have
these chat Bots we've had for a long
time but they used to lie and say
terrible things now they just lie and
that's interesting enough through big
advances in a field called Deep learning
giving us things like image enhancement
where you can make make your face into
whatever you want is giving us chat Bots
and there's also a whole lot more data a
lot of the AI That's popular right now
is very data hungry so now that we have
the data we get to taste the fruits of
these things sometimes we're better
sometimes for worse but at least we can
taste them now active manual Azalea one
asks I want to build a trillion dollar
AI company how do I go about it I've
never built a trillion dollar company I
built one company that did very well
what we did was we focused on a problem
that not many people were focusing on
then which was how to learn when you
don't have a lot of data I would say the
first thing you need to do is to learn a
bunch about AI I would recommend that
you not only study what is hip and
popular right now which is large
language models that a lot of your
competitors are going to study but you
study AI more broadly look at the
history of AI once you have like some
kind of Technology you also got to
figure out like why people would pay you
any money for it so there are a lot of
products out there where the technology
is pretty cool but people don't know how
to make it actually work sometimes even
when they know what the product should
be they have trouble so a good example
of that is driverless cars you could
imagine that driverless cars might be a
trillion dollar company but nobody knows
actually how to execute on the
technology at inspired jobs asks what
are the steps to build a large language
model AI the core of these things from a
technical perspective are neural
networks and the way that they work is
they have a bunch of inputs that we
think of as a little bit like neurons we
call them nodes that are connected to
some kind of output what's most people
are doing right now is self-supervised
learning so they're training a neural
network to have some inputs and then
their connections between these neurons
and those connections get tuned over
time so that the right things get
predicted as we get more experience now
Transformer models are actually more
complicated than this they add in
something called attention that's
helping the system essentially to know
what parts of a sentence are relevant at
any given moment so they can make best
predictions relative to that so instead
of just looking at the sequence of words
and kind of just looking at the last few
words they can look at a larger context
over time and essentially guess in
sensible ways relative to the data
they're trained on what you should have
next at any given point in time at Alex
Bazi asks is Furby AI Furby was a little
pet that looked like it was learning
language the thing about Furby that most
people don't know is that it was
pre-programmed to look like it was
developing like a human child say a
certain set of things on day one another
set of things on day two it was just an
illusion to make you think that it was
growing and learning but it wasn't
really next up at guide autonoma asks
how close are we to truly self-driving
cars I would say if you mean by a truly
self-driving car a car that can do what
an Uber can do the best demos that I
know of right now can do this but they
can only do it for specific locations
specific destinations with specific
routes the problem here is everybody
says okay well there are these outlier
cases the car doesn't know what to do if
you put in an airport and it has to
drive around a jet and Tesla actually
crashed into a jet because it was an
outlier case it wasn't something that
was stored in the cases that it had been
trained on it turns out there's just so
many any of these outlier cases that
nobody really has a solution for it I
think we will see limited release a
certain District in a downtown where
there's a lot of traffic maybe we have a
driverless car for there but the version
where you just don't drive anymore
that's many years away at s Hussein
ather asks is the Turing test outdated I
would say it's been outdated for a long
time and I wish people would stop
talking about it however since I am not
Emperor I cannot force people to stop
talking about it but what it is is a
test that says a machine would be
considered to be intelligent if it could
fool people turns out to be a lousy test
people are easily fooled the reality is
it's very hard to measure intelligence
nobody has a perfect way to do it
something that I've proposed would be a
comprehension challenge so you have a
system read something watch a movie it
has to explain what's going on if you
can answer questions about things like
what happens when we discover that the
thing that we thought was a bomb wasn't
or vice versa we can really understand
what's going on then I think that's a
sign of true intelligence at Rick did
asks what is intelligence intelligence
in the human brain is actually a lot of
different things visual intelligence and
verbal intelligence mathematical
intelligence so there are many aspects
to it but maybe the most important one
is flexibility being able to see
something new and be able to cope with
it human intelligence is full of flaws
we have confirmation bias we have lousy
memories but it's flexible and part of
it is that we can reason about things we
can deliberate about them most of
machine intelligence that we have right
now is really about pattern recognition
so for now I would say that human
intelligence is broader than machine
intelligence in some places machines can
go deeper like when they play chess but
I don't think they have the breadth so
far that humans do at FH man 19 what is
the major difference in the learning
styles of a human baby versus primates
versus current AI that makes current AI
inferior human babies primates when they
learn things they're learning about the
world the structure of the world how
objects interact how people interact and
I would say the current AI doesn't
really do that it's just storing
examples and looking for patterns it
doesn't build what a cognitive
psychologist would call a model of the
world a baby is trying to work stuff out
they're trying to work out how gravity
Works they're trying to work out you
know what happens to objects as they
change over time babies are like little
scientists and current AI system is
really mostly about learning
correlations without that causal
understanding of the world I just don't
think you have very much at tiblens
asked but what happens if the AI goes
Rogue first we should try hard not to
let that happen we should probably not
be working on making AI sentient I don't
think we necessarily want our AI to sit
around saying who am I why am I here and
why am I doing these things that humans
ask me when I could do other things we
should worry though about people using
large language models to control things
like electrical power grids there are
companies now who want to make current
AI which is limited in a bunch of ways
and connected to every bit of the world
software that seems like a scary mission
to me not because these systems are
going to go Rogue and deliberately want
to take over the world because they
don't understand the world and so
they're going to make bad decisions when
the world is different from how it was
when they were trained at smoke away
asks what is the best case scenario for
AI well the reason I work on AI is
because I think it could revolutionize
Science and Technology especially
biological science biology is really
complicated you have something like 20
000 genes and they make something like a
hundred thousand or a million different
proteins AI could help us make much
better solutions for medicine we have
things like Alzheimer's we've been
working for 50 years we don't have a
good answer hey I could probably help us
if we had a better AI help us figure out
how the brain works that would be
awesome AI could help us with climate
change by helping us build better
materials another case I think is Elder
Care robots so we're getting to a point
where we have a lot more elderly people
than young people if we could have
robots that are smart enough and
trustworthy enough that they could
really take care of the elderly people I
think that would be a big win last case
is tutors of course people are using
chat gbt as a tutor but you could
imagine really fantastic individualized
tutoring once the systems understand the
people who are learning better can help
figure out like where are they having a
problem at Katrina ferlic hi there asks
in what ways will the human mind always
Excel relative to AI we don't know all
the stuff that's in here there's 100
billion neurons and trillions of
connections between them right now ai is
no match for this at all not whatsoever
the versatility of this thing the Energy
Efficiency of this thing totally
unmatched by current AI 100 years from
now I can't promise that maybe we will
all have a good time Leisure Time and AI
will be able to handle all the things
that we can do don't know at machine
learn flx asks what's the difference
between AI machine learning and deep
learning let me draw that
deep learning is a technique for using
neural networks to predict things you
gave them data they try to predict that
data it's actually just one technique
for machine learning there's something
called decision trees there's something
called foosting there are many many
different techniques in machine learning
some of them have been around for 30
years some of them have been invented
last week
and machine learning is just part of
artificial intelligence so intelligence
encompasses all of machine learning
which encompasses all of deep learning
and AI has other techniques like search
and planning most of the focus recently
has been about deep learning and I think
because of the problems with
hallucinations and stuff like that
people are starting to look more broadly
again which is a good thing at C Garcia
e88 asks is deep learning really hitting
a wall this is actually a reference to a
paper I wrote called Deep learning is
hitting a wall and what I said in that
paper was that deep learning was making
progress in some ways but that it was
having trouble with truth and
reliability and the field went nuts and
got really mad at me and there was a
whole set of memes but then when
Microsoft rolled out Bing and Google
rolled out Bard we saw that those things
actually have huge problems with
reliability and have huge problems with
truthfulness it's true every day deep
learning looks better at being more and
more like a plausible human but these
problems are truthfulness and
reliability are not going away and that
is the wall and I stand by it at nft
dude for Life asks how will AI change
the way we work and live in the next
decade the honest truth is a decade is a
long time in the current Tech cycle and
I'm not sure how we're going to live in
the next 10 years the people who are
most immediately going to be affected
are people who do Commercial Art where
they're not inventing some new kind of
art but they're just like give me a
picture of this if it doesn't have to be
too specific you may not need a
commercial artist to do that anymore I
think that AI will probably change how
many cashiers we have in stores fairly
soon there's a lot of experiments around
that there's another problem which is
that the AI that we have now is good at
making misinformation and I think we may
live in a world in which there's even
more fake information and I I'm worried
that that's going to make us trust one
another less it's going to be a a very
exciting decade and where it is 10 years
I don't think anybody can firmly predict
that at FT opinion asks is it stealing
when generative AI produces algorithmic
art having trained on databases of human
artists work whether it's stealing is
ultimately going to depend on our
criteria what we count as stealing so we
know Human Art is certainly are
influenced by others musicians have
heard other people's work and so forth
but there's a way in which it's more
direct in a machine that might store a
million or a billion examples and get
much closer to the detail of what the
others have done I'm not going to make
an absolute decision here I think the
courts and the legal system have to
decide but there's definitely an element
of stealing there moving on at Irina
Cronin asks how are large language
models a Potential Threat to democracy
because you can use them to generate
misinformation at an amazing scale so
you can have a chat bot create thousands
or millions of whatever piece of garbage
you want to introduce into the world and
then if that's not good enough you can
say write studies make them longer and
write a paragraph about each of these
fake studies and so in the hands of
troll farms and we know they exist we
know there are Bad actors in the world
this becomes a tremendous tool one thing
is you get them to believe things that
aren't true another thing is you get
them to not believe anything democracy
doesn't really work if we don't know
what to believe and if we ruin people's
faith in the system and their knowledge
about what's going on how can they
possibly vote in informed ways at
edsuperia asks I spent a few days
learning more about large language
models and now I think they probably
shouldn't work as well as they
apparently do they're basically the
dumbest way of generating text how is it
that they work at all they're not really
a dumb way of generating tax they're
actually pretty sophisticated the
dumbest way would be to have a big
dictionary of everything that everybody
said before and say if I've seen these
three words what's the most likely
fourth word they kind of work that way
but they also do some generalization
taking related words and treating them
as if they're similar and that allows
them to say some things that are new but
stick pretty close to the things we've
seen before so it's like autocomplete on
steroids if you have enough data
autocomplete turns out to work pretty
well that's sibatha asks is AI really
that good or bad what is the worst case
scenario you can come up with when it
comes to AI well the best case is about
helping Science and Technology the worst
case I think is that it drives us into
the hands of fascism by undermining
trust and maybe even worse than that is
if we do make them sentient they get
upset and they want to put us all in
zoos I don't think that's super likely I
hope they always remain science fiction
but as the pace of AI accelerates we
should be thinking about them more and
more next question add Alexander Sumer
asks what will it take to make large
language models and AI systems more
broadly tell fewer lies and be more more
logically consistent first thing to say
is They Don't Really lie because they
don't really have intentions but they
say a lot of things that aren't true and
I don't think we can fix it within the
current Paradigm this is why I think we
need a paradigm shift the current
Paradigm is just about what is plausible
in this context people have said these
words what other words could I say here
and truth and logical consistency is
really about something different it's
about knowing facts and being able to
reason over those facts being able to
say if Socrates is a man and all men are
Immortal that it follows that Socrates
is moral and the way that these neural
networks are built that's just not part
of what they do we need to be able to
bridge these approaches I call that
neurosymbolic AI taking neural networks
plus symbol stuff and putting those
together we need to build Bridges
Between Two Worlds at Raphael Carreras
asks how much of ai's success is because
of Hardware custom AI chips new
architecture Etc it's a good question
there's a great paper by Sarah hooker
called the hardware Lottery the argument
that she makes is that the AI we're
doing now is mostly a function of the
chips that we're using right now this is
just a tiny little computer that you can
learn about microprocess sisters and how
to build circuits it's not a very
sophisticated chip this is not going to
power a large language model you could
power a very tiny language model with it
if you wanted to I would not be
surprised if 20 years from now people
look back at the current time and say
yeah they had all those gpus they
figured out what they could do with it
but that wasn't really the way to get to
artificial general intelligence maybe
somebody else had to find a different
chip or maybe everybody woke up when
they realized how much large language
models were lying they decided they just
needed to do something else even though
this was all very attractive at Phil jkc
who I believe I know hey there what
relevant physical attribute in the human
brain is missing in modern deep learning
architectures for performance why do we
have reason to believe that these are
relevant first thing to realize is deep
learning is sometimes called
biologically plausible it works in
something like the way the human brain
does but I would say that something is
very thin as we dig in we see structure
everywhere the brain is not just a
uniform piece of spam there are a
thousand different kinds of neurons and
if we did Dougie even further each
connection between neurons has something
like 500 different proteins there's a
lot of structure in how the brain works
it doesn't mean we understand it all but
our neural networks basically have one
kind of neuron that does one thing it
sums things up you know that's not
really how the brain works I would also
say that many people think we'll figure
out how to do AI by solving Neuroscience
I would say we actually need AI in order
to solve Neuroscience because the brain
is so complicated we probably can't do
it with our own feeble human brains we
probably need computers to help us to
figure out how the brain works but we're
going to have to do a better job of AI
before we get there
[Music]